bonjour nous sommes jeudi 26 février
merci de nous rejoindre dans file echo
l'émission qui revient sur l'actualité
économique locale
tout de suite le sommaire de notre
émission spéciale salon de l'agriculture
2015 à l'occasion de la 52e édition du
salon nous sommes allés à la rencontre
des agriculteurs exploitants illinois
vous le verrez c'est pour eux un rendez
vous économiques et stratégiques
importants ludovic biseau et
rambolitains il était dans les
finalistes du concours du meilleur
ouvrier de france fromager
nous l'avons suivi dole dernière étape
de ce concours d'excellence michel sapin
le ministre des finances et des comptes
publics est venue cette semaine à bazens
ville visiter le site de production du
groupe en danse et nautiques crise
l'occasion de faire le point pour lui
sur les dispositifs du soutien aux
entreprises
enfin dans notre entretien cette semaine
il est aussi consacrée au salon de
l'agriculture
nous parlerons du développement de
l'agriculture biologique et de sa
viabilité économique
dans les yvelines et en ile de france
pour cela nous avons rencontré marc
chauvin c'est un des représentants du
groupement des agriculteurs biologiques
il a accepté de répondre à nos questions
dans un entretien que nous avons
réalisés au salon de l'agriculture
mais avant cela je vous propose de
passer en revue l'actualité de la
semaine
et nous commençons cette émission avec
les chiffres du chômage ils ont été
dévoilés hier par pôle emploi
seule la catégorie à c'est-à-dire les
chômeurs n'ayant exercé aucune activité
depuis leur inscription a connu un léger
recul -0 3% dans les yvelines et moins
0,4 pour cent pour l'île de france en
janvier dans le département le chômage
est en hausse de 0 2% sur toutes les
catégories confondues le nombre de
demandeurs d'emploi passe de 80 à 2350 à
87 mille deux cents ce sont les seniors
qui sont les plus touchés par le chômage
les jeunes de moins de 25 ans sont moins
impactés en un an pour appel
l'augmentation des chiffres du chômage
et de 6% en ile-de-france
au total plus de 900 mille personnes
sont en situation de demandeur d'emploi
michel sapin ministres des finances et
des comptes publics est venu visiter le
site de production du groupe chris à
demain lille dans les yvelines je vous
disais dans le sommaire ce site emploie
plus de 400 personnes et il bénéficie du
cic le crédit d'impôt pour la
compétitivité et l'emploi depuis l'année
dernière
l'occasion pour le ministre de faire un
point sur les dispositifs de soutien aux
entreprises sur place
yolain thorez et patrick jacques de
dixmude à 15 heures hier michel sapin
ministres des finances et des comptes
publics fait son arrivée à bazens ville
dans les yvelines
là où depuis les années 80 le groupe
crise a installé son activité
industrielle et logistique
là aussi où depuis l'année dernière un
dispositif de soutien a été mis en place
le cic crédit d'impôt pour la
compétitivité et l'emploi
grâce à cela le site a perçu environ
350000 euros en 2014 et devrait toucher
600 mille euros cette année
de quoi pousser le groupe à investir le
conseil d'administration de krys group a
décidé d'investir 12 millions d'euros
pour le développement de son unité de
fabrication de verre pour faire des
verts haut de gamme
augmenter le service aux opticiens et
aussi pour développer l'activité
logistique du site en passant
en passant de 7 millions d'articles
transité par an à plus de 10 millions à
horizon 2016 développer l'activité s'est
aussi recruter des salariés
l'année dernière une vingtaine d'emplois
a déjà été créé et dans les deux ans à
venir
le groupe devrait encore embaucher une
quarantaine de personnes le cic eux
semblent alors fonctionner ici michel
sapin la découverte sur le terrain lors
de la visite une visite suivie d'une
table ronde sur les différents
dispositifs de soutien aux entreprises
plusieurs patrons ont pu échanger avec
le ministre j'ai surtout eu des
préoccupations sur mais est-ce que ça va
durer longtemps
est-ce que ça va continuer ma réponse
est oui inscrivez vous dans la durée
c'est un dispositif qui est là pour
faire en sorte que les charges des
entreprises diminue et diminue dans la
durée quand on investit on avait ce type
a pour trois mois ou pour un an
on investit pour dix ans le ministre l'a
affirmé les entreprises ont bénéficié de
plus de 40 milliards d'euros de baisses
de cotisations et d'impôts en l'espace
de quatre ans et nous restons sur le
thème du soutien aux entreprises chaque
année la banque de france réalise une
enquête sur les résultats des
entreprises et les perspectives de
l'année en cours ce bilan donne un
aperçu de la santé des entreprises
franciliennes
voici ses conclusions mélanie poquet et
david est charpentier
c'est plutôt l'optimisme qui ressort de
la synthèse sur la santé des entreprises
françaises et notamment francilienne 777
entreprises industrielles et 1234 dans
les services marchands ont été consultés
par la banque de france
l'entreprise en 2014 sur l'île de france
on peut considérer qu'elles se sont
plutôt bien comportés notamment dans le
secteur des services et au niveau de
l'industrie
la l'érosion du chiffre d'affaires qu'on
avait constaté par le passé est
aujourd'hui bloquée quant à l'emploi la
croissance de l'emploi donc à augmenter
assez fortement dans les services on
s'est stabilisée globalement dans
l'industrie dans l'industrie après deux
années consécutives de baisse avec -3 7%
en 2012 et moins 0,6 pour cent en 2013
le chiffre d'affaires en ile de france
s'est stabilisé avec 0 1% de hausse en
du côté des services marchands
l'augmentation est plus conséquente avec
+10 8% pour l'année passée de bons
résultats qui s'expliquent notamment par
la baisse des coûts des matières
premières ou la baisse de l'euro ona
aussi donc que les conditions de
financement qui sont aujourd'hui très
bonne pour les entreprises en termes de
tours notamment en france puisque la
plupart des demandes des entreprises que
ce soit pour des crédits de trésorerie
ou des crédits d'investissement sont
aujourd'hui satisfaite par le secteur
bancaire
je considère que l'accès au crédit des
entreprises aujourd'hui il est aisé à de
bonnes conditions
maintenant il est clair que le travail
des banquiers c'est aussi de
sélectionner et risque et donc le
banquier n'a pas vocation à prêter à des
entreprises en difficulté mais c'est
normal puisqu'on lui demande donc lui
aussi à deux d'être capable d'avoir une
activité rentable pour la banque de
france les perspectives 2015 devrait
voir ses améliorations s'accroître à
nouveau une reprise de l'activité est
attendue dans l'industrie du côté des
services marchands les prévisions
devrait être orienté à la hausse hier
soir la présidence de propofol a tenu sa
réunion mensuelle l'occasion de faire le
point sur la situation actuelle de la
pépinière d'entreprises selon le journal
toutes les nouvelles parues hier la
pépinière d'entreprises mettrait en
cause l'ancien directeur et représentant
de sparte pme une entreprise locataire
de promo paul qui a conduit également un
audit demandé par l'ancien président
pour l'heure le président élu de
l'opposition de trappes othmana sco se
dit confiant sur l'avenir de propofol je
vous propose de l'écouter
alors sur le plan financier on a engagé
toute une série de mesures d'urgence
d'économie assez drastiques pour
effectivement propolis
continuer à fonctionner donc ça c'est un
effort de gestion qui a porté ses fruits
et puis en parallèle on l'engagé tout
une négociation avec les créanciers les
partenaires bancaires
la ville de trappes qui est également un
partenaire afin qu'on puisse trouver une
solution à moyen terme et aujourd'hui
ces discussions là ne sont pas encore
achevé mais elles sont bien engagées et
la survie de promo paul n'est pas en
danger en tout cas à court terme pour le
moment et j'ai bon espoir qu'on puisse
en sortir par le haut dans les tout
prochains mois
la procédure de conciliation lancé au
mois de novembre dernier devraient se
terminer au plus tard le 12 avril
prochain
il est maintenant temps de passer à
notre dossier spécial sur le salon de
l'agriculture 2015
cette semaine à l'occasion de la 52e
édition du salon de l'agriculture nous
vous proposons une émission spéciale
nous sommes allés au parc des
expositions de versailles
nous avons rencontré les yvelinois
présents pour l'événement un des thèmes
phares du salon c'est l'agriculture
biologique avec 5,5 pour cent de ces
exploitations agricoles et 1,1 million
d'hectares cultivés en bio
le secteur est en plein essor en france
nous avons rencontré marc chauvin y est
un des représentants du groupement des
crues des agriculteurs biologiques
il a accepté de répondre à nos questions
sur la viabilité économique et
l'actualité de ce secteur
regardez cet entretien réalisé au sein
même du salon de l'agriculture 2015 nous
sommes ici au salon de l'agriculture
sur le second du groupement des
agriculteurs biologiques d'île de france
avec marque sort un billet plainte et
représentants bonjour et merci de
répondre à leurs questions alors tout
d'abord mais ce chemin gens du cru bon d
un petit peu voilà un petit état des
lieux des agriculteurs il dit non
l'agriculture biologique donc en
effectivement dans les yvelines on a à
peu près 44 agriculteurs en
convertis en agriculture en agriculture
biologique ça représente à peu près 4 24
% de l'ensemble des agriculteurs
ce qui est au dessus de la moyenne de
l'île de france puisque nous de france
on est autour de 3,9 pour cent et en
termes de s a eu qui la surface agricole
utile on est aux environs de d'un peu
plus de 3 3% quoi ce qui est aussi
effectivement au dessus de la moyenne de
l'île de france qui se situe à 1,6 pour
cent
alors comment on peut expliquer le fait
que voilà c'est un département qui
on n'est pas encore suffisamment
développée en analogique est ce que ces
situations qui
si un peu particulière oui c'est un peu
commun à beaucoup de départements
agricoles alors il y a
il ya beaucoup de facteurs il ya
effectivement pour les personnes qui
veulent passer sur l'agriculture
biologique
il leur faut à la fois effectivement une
certaine motivation il faut qu'ils
soient attirés et après effectivement ce
changement là c'est pas quelque chose
qui se prend à la légère
ça se réfléchit parce que derrière il ya
des conséquences à la fois en termes
techniques pour conduire une ferme en
agriculture biologique et après il ya
aussi tout un système dead qu'il faut
appréhender qu'il faut bien comprendre
et puis avec ça il faut aussi s'assurer
au niveau des débouchés comment on va
pouvoir effectivement
pro d'une vente ses proches sa
production tout simplement
leur même impression qu en france à gros
budget prendre un essor se développe
-
expliquez vous justement les
agriculteurs aient du mal à siemens est
ce que finalement c'est vraiment viable
économiquement
aujourd'hui la plupart des exploitations
bio sont largement viable plus viable
effectivement que le conventionnel
globalement c'est beaucoup plus stable
parce qu'il ya moins de variations au
prix mais effectivement aujourd'hui
c'est pour ça qu aurait aujourd sein du
du groupe
peut-être que tout biologique ile de
france on est en train de faire
effectivement de monter une coopérative
de commercialisation qui va permettre
effectivement aux agriculteurs bio
actuelle déjà de se diversifier d'avoir
des débouchés supplémentaires
c'est une association 6-1 et plus ni
moins et en même temps ça devrait être
un très très bon levier pour
les personnes qui veulent se convertir
justement est aujourd'hui effectivement
dans les yvelines
8 novembre prochain on organise
régulièrement des journées des visites
chez un agriculteur bio et sur lequel on
répond on avait été conventionnel
pourrait-on alors question pour leur
expliquer effectivement quels sont les
accompagnements à la fois d'un point de
vue administratif mais d'un point de vue
technique ce qui est très important et
aussi pour parler des débouchés pas
effectivement dans les prochains il ya
effectivement aux mureaux il ya
effectivement une
une opération comme ça ne sais quoi vous
vous êtes légalement polyculteur est ce
que vous pouvez me dire concrètement
quelles sont exclus des difficultés mais
maintenu qu'on veut soumettre à
l'agriculture biologique est ce que
finalement ça fait plus cher d'être un
agriculteur bio alors le coût de revient
ou ccc plus cher leur en terme au niveau
administratif il n'y a pas de grand
changement puisque en fait on est soumis
aux mêmes réglementations
on a quand même des aides
supplémentaires ce qui n'est pas
négligeable des aides à la fois la
conversion et une fois qu'on est
convertie après ce qui est très
important c'est d'avoir un suivi
technique et de lettres technique parce
qu'on est obligé de revoir l'ensemble de
ses rotations sécheval en culture
revoir certains outillage parce qu'on va
utiliser d'autres choses
donc là effectivement il ya besoin
vraiment d'un appui technique pour les
agriculteurs en marche mais j'ai envie
de vous demander escure là il faut
prévoir un budget en investissement
important qu'on veut se convertir à
l'agriculture biologique des tranchées
d'un ordre d'idée si vous prenez par
exemple quelqu'un qui a déjà un élevage
de volailles poulets de chair et qui a
déjà l'infrastructure l'investissement
va pas être énorme
par contre effectivement si vous êtes
dans un plutôt aux grandes cultures et
que vous avez besoin d'acheter d'une
variante du matériel de désherbage
mécanique est faut prévoir un budget
plus important qui est important en
termes de conversion
c'est effectivement de prévoir une
trésorerie puisque en fait quand on
commence à une conversion les produits
ne sont pas automatiquement à gré issus
de l'agriculture biologique mais un laps
de temps il ya des global m'ont presque
trois ans de conversion sur lequel les
produire en c1 et en c2 ne sont pas
commercialisés au prix du bio même si le
coût de production
c'est identique à celui du bio
est-ce-qu'il des filières où c'est plus
facile de se convertir au bio que
d'autres oui bah en général les gens qui
font de l'élevage qui peut volailles de
chair poules pondeuses
c'est beaucoup plus simple puisque en
fait c'est simplement
je connais pas en plus devient une ferme
qui est aujourd'hui en
en poules pondeuses de plein air en fait
ils ont déjà toute l'infrastructure
la seule chose qui va changer ça va être
la nourriture et de globalement et puis
le nombre de poules qui vont mettre
effectivement dans leurs bâtiments et
leur part qu'en classe est très présent
dans les idées il ya plusieurs équations
agriculteurs qui sont reconversion vous
les accompagnez pour vous les aidez
justement dans ce processus de rotation
pour aller vers l'agriculture biologique
de mémoire il y en a cinq qui sont en
fait ils ont commencé déjà à se
convertir et puis ils agrandissent
puisque la conversion se fait par étapes
et puis à trois nouvelles effectivement
trois nouvelles conversions et donc on
les aide allait effectivement d'un point
de vue comme jésus tu as l'air
d'apprendre administratif pour savoir à
quelle est disons droit comment il faut
organiser avoir tenant les tenants et
les aboutissants et puis ensuite on va
les aider d'un point de vue technique
principalement sur comment faire des
nouvelles rotations
quelle culture après l'autre globalement
de profiter des erreurs que les plus
anciens on a fait de beaux qu'ils ne
fassent pas des mêmes tout simplement
et puis ensuite au siliana par un aspect
très important
c'est effectivement les moyens de
commercialisation puisque en fait on a
en ile de france et il ya beaucoup de
lait restauration collective les
restaurants il ya beaucoup de demandes
pour avoir du produit non pas brut mais
effectivement qu'il soit déjà et soit
pré cuits soit des choses comme ça
phinney
une dernière question est ce que c'est
une démarche que l'on va faire avec des
consommateurs est justement les
accompagner ou aller vers eux pour aussi
les sensibiliser à l'agriculture
biologique
il ya deux choses aujourd'hui c'est
qu'effectivement il ya beaucoup de
consommateurs qui viennent vers nous
quand on organise des visites à la ferme
il ya beaucoup d'enfants général en plus
du succès il ya tous des mouvements tels
que les amap et tout ça sur lequel
effectivement il ya vraiment un
partenariat entre le producteur un
consommateur
et puis fit a effectivement aussi à nous
de faire connaître l'agriculture
biologique est allé effectivement sur
les événements comme le salon
il ya une démarche aujourd'hui des deux
côtés des consommateurs qui viennent
vers nous et les agriculteurs qui vont
dans les consommateurs bien merci marche
avant d'avoir répondu à nos questions
on continue notre émission spéciale sur
le salon de l'agriculture avec le
chiffre de la semaine
1050 c'est le nombre d'exposants
présents au salon de l'agriculture cette
année jusqu'à dimanche cette 52e édition
mobilise également 300 villes selon les
organisateurs ces 20 % de plus par
rapport à l'année dernière une mesure
mise en place en raison du plan
vigipirate alerte attentats et les
exposants les agriculteurs présents au
salon de l'agriculture viennent de toute
la france vous savez et contrairement à
ce que l'on pourrait croire la première
région agricole du pays c'est
l'ile-de-france le territoire des
yvelines représente lui 89 milles
hectares de terres agricoles et compte
près de 1000 exploitations
nous avons rencontré les représentants
yvelinois présent sur le salon chacun
misé sur cet événement comme vous allez
le voir
regardez ce reportage réalisé avec
williams elle xavier jaglin pour le
montage
pour cette 52e édition ils sont plus de
1000 exposants à occuper un stand sur le
salon
parmi eux à peine une dizaine divine
ouah c'est pourtant un rendez vous
stratégique pour les agriculteurs et
exploitant le département la ferme du
logis situé près de thoiry est venu
montrer ses spécialités à base de fruits
c'est la première fois qu'elle participe
au salon de l'agriculture
les sorbets ont un succès fou ouais un
bon petit corner pendant les années
c'est vraiment top notre principal
motif d'être ici c'est vraiment que de
faire venir nos genres dans les
exploitations pour que voilà pour qu'il
vienne nous rencontrer
on se fait connaître bon c'est vraiment
super on vend nos produits on vend les
produits dérivés de la cueillette mais
ce qu'on voudrait vraiment c'est donner
l'adresse de notre sphère aux gens
l'occasion de se faire connaître pour
les nouveaux et de décrocher des
médailles pour les habitués chaque année
la ferme grignon prend un stand au salon
cette fois elle n'est plus dans le
prestigieux pavillon 1
quinze mille euros pour la semaine une
dépense importante elle a plutôt préféré
un emplacement à 700 euros
clairement c'est pas rentable
économiquement
puisque même avec la vente des produits
on couvre pas le prix du stand
mais voilà en termes de communication
c'est quand même assez important et
c'est un outil c'est l'outil que voilà
qui nous permet d'être d'être visible
sur salon aussi important que je suis
l'agriculture malgré ces dépenses le
salon représente une vitrine importante
pour les producteurs et agriculteurs ce
rendez-vous permet aussi d'agrandir de
valoriser sa clientèle plus que les
particuliers ce sont les professionnels
qui sont visés benoît dupré responsable
de la ferme de viltain toute la journée
il fait des allers retours entre son
stand et ses rendez vous professionnels
c'est l'occasion salants de rencontrer
nos clients et là on attend
une collectivité qui s'appelle air de
ses casinos c'est une restauration
scolaire restauration d'entreprise
donc on a déjà trois restaurants
d'entreprises qui sont gérés par air de
ses casinos par exemple
a jouy en josas à thales à vélizy le
synchrotron de saclay donc bah ils
viennent aujourd'hui qu'on a rencontrés
sur le salon alors voyez quand on les
reçoit
je capte pas mon tablier j'ai prendre ma
veste
d'abord froid dehors pour les accueillir
on fait une très belle visite du salon
je leur présentais avec des animaux et
puis on finit sur le store d'avec un
petit jus de pomme de la ferme
une opération séduction qui revient en
moyenne à 5000 euros pour cinq jours
mais l'événement reste un bon
investissement l année dernière plus de
sept cent mille visiteurs se sont
pressés dont nous avions du salon mardi
le salon de l'agriculture a accueilli
les épreuves finales du concours du
meilleur ouvrier de france classe
fromage est un titre très convoité
dix candidats y participent et parmi eux
ludovic biseau un fromager rambolitains
nous l'avons suivi dans les phases
finales
vous allez découvrir ce concours
exceptionnel qui récompense l'excellence
un reportage réalisé avec william el
rumor espionné pour le montage pas une
minute à perdre pour ludovic bisous le
regard soucieux le fromager et concentré
il est 7 heures du matin au salon de
l'agriculture les épreuves finales du
concours du meilleur ouvrier de france
classe fromager commence ludovic s'est
préparée 18 mois pour ce grand jour
il a réussi plusieurs étapes pour
arriver jusqu'à l'épreuve du
chef-d'oeuvre 3h15 pour réaliser un
plateau remarquable avec plus de 50
fromage sous les yeux attentifs des
jurés thème de cette année
retour vers le futur
que certains vont peut-être abordé côté
ciné cinématographique avec la trilogie
mais nous on n'a pas vu ça on a vu
simplement retour vers le futur
savoir d'où l'on vient pour savoir où
l'on va donc il ya de la tradition chez
nous s'appelle ici les gens qu'on
fabrique du fromage en france et puis eh
bien il ya le quotidien du premier qui
essaye d'innover en permanence les seins
c'est le futur
au fil de l'épreuve les plateaux se
révèle plus spectaculaire le seigneur de
la compétition a eu comme les autres
candidats plusieurs mois pour réfléchir
au thème pour le décor il a pu compter
sur l'aide du musée rambolitains de
rambouillet je voulais faire un petit
train électrique et je voulais faire
passer un train dans un tunnel creusé
dans un fromage
c'était la base du concept qui avait un
sens parce que c'est le trad au 19e
siècle qui a permis au fromage d'arriver
dans les villes avant dans les villes on
consommait que des fromages de sa région
où l'horloge tourne
en plus du décor il faut disposer les
fromages soigneusement coupé à une heure
de la fin de l'épreuve ludovic se blesse
et la pression monte donc on commet en
ré france est vraiment laid les gestes
et les le travail qu'on fait un peu tous
les jours chacun dans nos boutiques dans
nos caves dans la sélection des produits
donc qui a rien qui change vraiment sauf
qu'on a le stress parce que
vous êtes là il ya le public dans le
public sa famille et ses proches n'a
ludovic ne doit pas leur parler
il reste concentré et déjà l'épreuve
s'achève
dernière épreuve la technique de coupe
maîtrise créativité les finalistes sont
aussi jugés sur la précision de leurs
gestes
plusieurs candidats peuvent être
consacrés meilleur ouvrier de france
mais il arrive parfois que personne ne
gagne le titre ça reste un concours donc
il peut y avoir de très bons
professionnels sans colle blanche midi
le concours se termine
ludovic rejoint son fan-club le fromager
est épuisé mais soulagé pour moi c'était
l'épreuve la plus difficile c'est
l'épreuve qui comptent le plus dans la
note globale
c'est l'épreuve la plus dure certains de
mes confrères redoutait l'oral
si hier on a eu un oral devant un grand
jury
moi j'avais moins peur de lowrie parce
que je confiance dans la capacité à
exprimer
je savais que j'étais un peu trop
ambitieux en termes de temps le jury
composé de meilleurs ouvriers de france
va maintenant examiner les
chefs-d'oeuvre la délibération va durer
plus de quatre heures il ne reste plus
qu'à attendre les résultats annoncés
dans la soirée
le lendemain nous retrouvons ludovic il
est de retour dans sa fromagerie à
rambouillet bonjour werver le fromager
porte fièrement son col bleu blanc rouge
le jury lui a décerné le titre de
meilleur ouvrier de france ils ne sont
que deux à avoir été consacré cette
année je savais aussi que si mon nom
sortait pas en premier les temps par
balles fab éthiques
c'était foutu et mon nom est sorti et
les domaines biseau rambouillet après
après émotions fierté les amis et
clients tout en bas super hier ils ont
suivi la compétition sur internet
aujourd'hui ses clients viennent pour le
féliciter
je suis juste quelques pas je suis un
peu fier pour produit quoi tout le
travail qu'il a dû qu'elle a dû faire
franchement peut pas dire autre chose
que je suis vraiment fier pour lui pour
le concours ludovic s'est imposé un
rythme de vie stricte coucher à 10
heures lever à 4 heures du matin pendant
un an pour s'entraîner un investissement
également financier
quinze mille euros sont à prévoir pour
pallier les frais du concours tout cela
est maintenant derrière lui ludovic
commencent à prendre conscience de sa
nouvelle vie ce qui va changer
déjà je pense qu'il y aura un petit
appel
cet appel d'air au niveau de la demande
ça va attirer plus de clients donc
essayer d'y faire face
ceci dit moi j'ai pas de grosses
ambitions de développement je rêve pas
d'ouvrir un réseau de points de vente
il y a 6 ans ludovic travailler en
costume derrière un bureau
aujourd'hui le nouveau meilleur ouvrier
de france et l'ambassadeur de sa
profession et cela pour la vie c'est ce
qu'on appelle une reconversion réussie
c'est la fin de notre émission merci de
nous avoir suivis je vous donne rendez
vous la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de file echo je vous
souhaite une très bonne soirée